欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
那接下来我们一个个来讲解
先讲解实力优品怎么样去提升它的数量
那么首先你要考虑一个问题就是
你想提升这个实力优品的数量
那么你知道什么样的产品能成为实力优品吗
或者是实力优品它有什么样最低的标准吗
那么你先把它的规则理解了
再去选择使用对应的方法
那么就能够快速的提升它的优品数量
我们要把产品变成实力优品
可以选择平台的新品
也可以选择把我们自己最近30天
发布在店铺里面的新品
去提升成为实力优品
另外的话我们也可以根据下面这些
品词的优品
把它转化成为实力优品
那么具体的提升方法是怎么样的呢
通常我们的实力优品
之前呢
它的规则是
一个RTS产品只要有一个订单
也就是一个买家数
它就成为实力优品
而定制的产品呢
它只要有一个寻盘或者是
两个寻盘
它就能够成为实力优品
既然这个规则已经给我们
明确了
那么我们是不是就要针对这些规则
去操作来满足它的条件
才能够让我们的实力优品更多呢
第一个就是我们通过
直通车推广跟问鼎鼎掌
来进行推广来实现的
实力优品数量提升的目标
第一个就是
我们要每周都去发一些新的产品
因为发新品它会有
三个月的流量扶持期
那么这些新品是
比较容易获得循环的
只要它获得一个循环那么你的
实力优品是不是就增加了一个
如果你是发
定制类的产品的话那么我们只需要
去推广一下马上把这些新发的产品去用新品加速计划去推广那么很快
它能够获得一个循环那么马上就变成了实力优品如果你的
计划里面有多个
新品那么就会
多个新品都成为实力优品那么如果你是RTS的话
如果你去靠推广的话那么难度又比较大因为有些
产品并不是那么容易
被下单的
所以RTS的话我们可以
去
绑定一些我们的信保订单
提升我们的买家的数量成为
实力优品
从载到爆品
只要需要绑定一个
信保订单
它的这个RTS就成为了
实力优品
第三个就是我们要去挖掘一些蓝海的款式, 也就是最近我们行业
哪些款式在流行
那么我去发的这些产品以及用最近增长的这些关键词去
组合标题去发产品
那么这些产品也更容易获得选盘跟订单
从而也能够更快的变成实力优品
这是一种其中的一种方法
第四个呢我们
定制的产品可以采用补询盘
RTS产品
可以通过补订单就是
补买家数量来提升这个操作的话需要你有一定的买家
账号
以及你的有海外的一些
付款的账号就可以实现了
因为这些都是我们
自己人为操作的
可以是你线下的客户把他们的订单搬到线上来进行成交或者是
让他们去
支付这一笔
货款我们自己去起草
订单去绑定
这些产品就可以了
第五个就是拓展新品类发新品比如说你本来有
1到3个品类
那么你通过
拓展品类可能有5到
8个品类
那么是不是你的品类更多了那么你去发的产品是不是能够覆盖更多的关键词
那么是不是有更多的
产品的总量
那么你的实力优品是不是会有所增加
第六个第七个第八个这些
无论你是做
提升实力优品
数量还是提升
店铺报品的总量
那么都是可以采用下面这三个方法的这三个方法是通用的比如说做房客营销
EDM营销
报RQ
或者是你RTS产品报名活动
以及报名其他的
场景活动
加设置一点设置折扣
优惠券等等都有利于提升他的一个
订单量
最后一个就是直播短视频都绑定我们自己
想要快速提升的那些报品
和
实力优品
就可以了
这个就是关于
实力优品
的提升
的方法
那么
上面的这些思路
可以
用你最擅长的就可以了
并不是我们都能用上
因为有些品类它是
只适合几个方法去应用就可以了如果你能够用的越多
那么肯定是越好的
所以我们只需要
根据我们
店铺的现状
产品的优势
去选择
更加符合我们的方法
并且快速的
把这些方法应用到位
就可以了
那么你的整个店铺的实力优品总量
肯定会
在持续的提升
另外提醒一点的就是
实力优品很有可能到时候如果数据不满足了
那么他就会变成
非实力优品那么他
你的
实力优品如果不增加那么整体的数据就是会下降
所以这个一定要重视起来
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
这个就是实力优品的提升的方法
如果你之前没有用过
里面的一些方法那么现在可以去尝试使用这些方法